お祀りしましたハンバーガー当選者発表です
曲名が2人50名が2名計4名に当たります
阿蘇は一応僕の事務所から送りかつになってます
開けた気ねー
誰か言っちゃダメなんですけどまっすぐ当選者を発表していきましょう
マヤ混ぜあれだよなんかあたらんじゃなかったからって何か俺 new 攻撃してこ
ないでね
俺のさぁみんなであげたいんだけどできないんだよ
だからなぁた目はなんか当たらない当たらないかじゃ叫んだとか
なんかまず最悪とか言われても僕はも知らぬ
ねおやつそうだよ
誇る方法がしてくれねあの当たらないのが普通です
もう当たらないです皆ハンバーガーはもらえませんみんなもらえません残念でした
近し
なんとなんとですねその中からでも4名が当たるっていう感じなんで
そういうスタンスでみてくださいもう当たらないからねもうね
当たらないからお前はぜひ当たらないからとへスターズで見て頼むよホントに入って
いったと思うんですけどコメントに解説ででも失格なんでコード方もちゃんとチェック
させていただきます
コメント数やマイナーなんだねー個性ほしいほしいほしいとか連打したらスプーンに
なるんですよ
ちょっとそれも僕改造しといたんで皆さん安心してください皆さんはちゃんとあります
はいやってまいりますではいきましょう積荷はいハンバーガー動画をアップされたのは
3週間前です
ベンチを見てもわかると思うんですけど一番さん
所に湖面退出コメント車人がこの形で
おやす愛してるおい3週間前からスタートして
クイーン
ときて
はい
517分前も最近ついさっきまでコメントしてくれますこれまでの全部のコメント
こちらに3万件
あるはずですのでなかったら僕のせいじゃないです
じゃあ全部のコメントここにあるんでこっから僕愚行スクロールして適当に4人選び
ます凄いな3万人も皆さんありがとう
また機会があったらなんかビッグなルートするのでまたぜひ
押して下さいじゃあ行きますじゃあまずはね俺なら楽しいなあこの取材者があってい
たら気分がいいね
まず50本の人ができます
1人目
ハンバーガ50個プレゼントしてる見に行きます50個プレゼントの1人目です
よし行くぞ
scroll スタート
どうなってる
どうなってすごい動いてるん
はいこの人この人ですこの人です
アーマード動いすらちゃん
はいじゃあこの人はこの人ん
くださいませご主人様続き成立ロー3はいおめでとうございます
成長だ
はい
草俺が欲しいです続き生一同様ハンバーガー50校おめでとうございます
俺が欲しいのは次は鈴木誠一郎をからスタートしを
鈴木千市からスタートします
よしさは浜が50件も50ハンバーグ50個目の2人目です
はい
ちょっと何かこれは分かりづらいか薄めで開けて留雄
さあさあさあさあ
はいこの人です
さあ誰でしょ
ラックカードめっちゃ欲しいです一日一食なので全字幕お願いします
操 gn 応援さんおめでとうございます
確認しました応募要件達成してますおめでとうございます
そう俺が欲しい39目立つ
遊びはここまでだぞ次は100校2名様にプレゼントです
彼らのます操さんのとこからスタートします
sato
結構下までも行っちゃおスタまで行っちゃう
下まで行っ
第二まで行ってかなぁ
はいこの人です
河南江席加奈子さんハーイ
小沢氏3番捕手でたまりませんお願いですください
私は僕はハンバーガーに選ばれて生まれてきた人間だと思います
始めた超大好きですお願いしますはいおめでとうございます100校です
はい大丈夫です大予言たせいです天気か何かおめでとう
神田キャッチャー猫ラブとかなと
おっな5敗
うらやましいですねザーもうラストですよ最後の1個ですハンバーガー100個
待ってスクロール選ぶとか本当に
適当で申し訳ないです
あの適当なのか僕だと思ってるんで適当に選ばせて頂きます the last 100
校いきます
これいいわこのキーを押して君なさい5
まぁ結局にまぁ結局家代に当たろうと僕にあまり関係ないんです皆さんにこう平等に
感謝してるんで
またまたまたったくないてあんまり
僕にはむしろも僕ら食べたいなぁくらいなんで
どうですかねぇ
もう見えてないんですけれども
そろそろいいかな
財木はスラストですはい
こいつ弾
前 t いつも動画を見てて欲しいと思いますてほしいですお願いしますさえ生まれ t
さんおめでとうございます id 3長兼しっかりクリアしていますおめでとうござい
ます
というわけで今回はですねえと50個がせ月誠一郎さんと操
時の a さんで100個が席なつこさんと前 t さんでございました
おめでとうございます今後もねまぁと恋プレゼント買った是非
やろうと思うんで
またヨロシク今だと4名の方は8僕からメッセージを送らせて頂くんでぜひご編集の方
お待ちしております
じゃ
dee ん
ぷっ